[Music]
this morning in our Saturday session
Jason is bull and the four hundred unit
the band formed in 2008 and has just
released their latest album critics
calling it one of the best of the year
fronted by 38 year old is bull the album
Markson bit of a change in the way he's
writing songs these days he'll perform
with the 400 unit in just a bit but
first we spoke at the Gibson guitar
showroom here in New York some people
have described it as a second act for
you does it feel like a second act for
you maybe so boy if it is that is one
lopsided play I think I'd put that act
first in a play if I want to keep people
in the seats
Jason Isbell has produced a trilogy of
acclaimed albums since he got sober
[Music]
his breakout record southeastern won the
Americana Music Award
never
so for sure his next something more than
free won two Grammy Awards
and his latest the Nashville sound
he's already making best of the year
list yeah yeah definitely
when I got sober and started working on
southeastern everything changed
everything about my life changed about
my work changed I stopped waiting on
inspiration and you know started working
really really hard he's become one of
the country's most acclaimed songwriters
Jason Isbell is the best lyric writer of
my generation John Mayer has tweeted he
lives at a level where even great
writers can only visit that's evident on
the new album
in the unlikely title love song if we
were vampires
[Music]
where do vampires come from well now
that's not a question for me that's the
question is the oldest time I started it
by really trying to deconstruct a
certain kind of love song a list song so
here are the things that I like about
you you're the things that I love about
you by the time I got to the chorus it
sort of occurred to me that it's the
expiration date you know we would never
be motivated to have relationships or to
have the courage to tell somebody how we
feel if we were gonna live forever so
that's where the chorus came from and
what a beautiful word vampires is you
know it's not a song you'd think you'd
hear coming from a 38 year old no but
that's the job that's the job you know
John Prine wrote hello in there when he
was 20 his bowl began to look at life
differently after he married fiddle
player amanda shires and became aware
the clock is always ticking when do you
think that most became apparent to you
well when I became a parent those issues
their daughter Mercy Rose is now almost
2 definitely in that moment you think oh
that's what we are it's terrifying it's
like oh we're that fragile always you
know and this whole thing is just that
you know and then it's done and and
there's beauty in that because why why
bother
otherwise